- If you're taking on debt
to go to college today,
unless you're going to a
top three percent school,
you're in deep fucking shit.
(upbeat music)
You've got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
- Good morning.
- Morning.
- Thanks for coming.
- Thanks for having me.
- Yeah, to your place.
- Yes.
- Really cool.
It's really far from
Montclair, New Jersey, though.
- I'm aware.
- Yeah but--
- I always get excited
when somebody gets transferred
from Hudson Yards to here
and lives in Jersey.
We find out their true grit.
- Definitely.
So you said today's a good
day because the sun's out.
- Yes, I like the sun.
- I've never not seen you in a good mood.
- That's true.
I'm fairly, I'm
consistently in a good mood.
I have a fairly solid
perspective on what life's about
and it puts me into a pretty good mood.
- But don't you think the one thing
that all of us
entrepreneurs have in common
is being so positive
and seeing the glass full?
- Yes, I think optimism,
I think really successful entrepreneurs
use an incredible concoction
of optimism and practicality.
I think the fine line
between optimism and delusion
is extremely fascinating
and I do think that's where
a lot of entrepreneurs fail.
But I couldn't agree with you more.
I'm in the yes business
and that causes a lot of mistakes
but only in the micro.
And I think the macro of
being in the yes, positive,
half glass full business is essential
for big impacts and successes.
- You knew you were an
entrepreneur at seven.
- Yes.
- You didn't just have a lemonade stand.
- No.
- You had a lemonade empire.
- Franchise.
- Franchise, okay, what does that mean?
- It means I was able
to trick Robbie Turnick
and Marissa Bird and Eric
Godfrey and Michael Bromfman
and Andy Grecco
into standing behind lemonade stands
while I made signs and put
them on trees and posts.
- Okay, that was at seven.
- Yes.
- I had a store when I was
about 12 with my friends.
It was a great store.
- In your own home?
- Unfortunately, it was in the basement
so not a lot of foot traffic
and no internet back
then but it was a start.
- I get it.
- I made cool stuff.
- You tricked people into going downstairs
and buying stuff.
- I did.
I think my parents were our biggest.
- Always great customers.
- Yeah.
And how do you balance,
okay, first of all,
the first time I met you,
I had no idea who you are.
I'm like, I don't know,
I came in, we had a meeting
- Nick Dio's like,
"Meet this person."
- Yeah, meet this person.
Okay, it took a year.
I came in and an hour I spent with you,
I fell in love instantly
like, this is the coolest guy.
Now everybody knows you.
I would say about 90%
of the people know you.
Mickey Drexler didn't know you.
I'm like, Mickey.
Now Mickey knows you.
Now Mickey goes in to meetings
saying to people, "Do you know Gary Vee?
"What do you mean you
don't know Gary Vee?"
So you're infectious.
- I think positivity is very real.
I think that intent is,
when I try to psychoanalyze myself
which I do a lot, I really do,
I do realize what I'm
attracted to in other people
is what people are attracted to with me.
It's why I'm attracted to you.
I think people that have good intent
and one thing I'm very positive of
is if somebody doesn't need somebody else
or wants something from somebody else,
they become unbelievably infectious
and I would say a weakness of mine
is my deep desire to not
need anything from anybody
at all times
which makes me unbelievably
likable to a lot of people,
especially in the long term
because I think my
personality and my Jerseyness
and my cursing and my bravado,
especially in public settings,
I think sometimes
confuses people at first.
In the long term,
it really works out.
I'm very happy to be
charismatic and likable.
It makes me happy, I like people a lot.
And more importantly,
I'm very 51/49.
I like the leverage,
and this is just the truth,
I like the leverage of
giving more than I ask for.
It's my comfortable place.
- But there's got to be days
where you wake up and say,
"I don't want to talk to a soul."
- Never.
- "I am tired,
"I'm exhausted."
It's yin and yang.
You need to recharge sometimes.
- No, no, I recharge all the,
I'm very into recharging.
- What time did you get up today?
- This morning, seven, 6:47.
- Okay.
So you did not exercise this morning?
- I did from seven to eight.
- You have a trainer?
- I do.
- That comes every day?
- Every day, travels with me.
- That's awesome.
- I've really gotten interested
in why people that can afford it
are more likely to buy a painting
than to hire somebody full
time to travel with them
and make them healthier.
I'm fascinated by this.
I'm fascinated by that.
Things fascinate me,
people wanting to buy things
over buying time, convenience or health
is something I'm spending a
lot of time thinking about.
- That's amazing,
especially as I'm
entering the health world.
There's nothing better than being healthy.
There's nothing.
- That's right.
And by the way, jumping to mental,
back to stress, anxiety,
things of that nature,
jumping from food and cardio
and things of that nature,
I think everybody's different.
I think everybody needs different things.
I know what my strengths
and weaknesses are.
On the recharging thing,
it's really interesting,
I've said this before and I
think people gloss over it,
the New York Jets are
a big refresher for me
because when you're an entrepreneur,
since I've been 22 years old,
the thing that I probably
take the most pride in
is that from the day I graduated school,
from the day I came home
from Mount Ida College
to this second
I have been the last stop
in the business that I'm in.
I am the operator,
the buck falls with me and you know this
and anybody listening knows this,
the level of anxiety
when you have to worry about everything,
and now in today's world with digital,
the fact that when I wake
up at 6:47 in the morning,
the first thing I have to do,
let me rephrase, that's not fair,
the first thing I do
is I look at my phone
and I have to look at all those texts
and thank God there's no fire in London,
thank God,
for me it's like, the
scariest things go in order.
Number one, getting a phone
call in the middle of the night,
scary 'cause you're just scared.
You're just scared
somebody's sick or dying.
Next is that hundredth of a
second before I look at my phone
'cause I know I'm gonna look at texts
which are only about fires or issues.
Nobody's texting me and
my 900 employees saying,
"Have a rad day, today,"
or like, "Sun is rocking."
It is, this is on fire, this
is fucked up, this is an issue
and so--
- But then how do you let it go
to go work out with your trainer?
- Easily
because I'm in the business
of being a firefighter.
It's so funny.
I actually think the great
comp to an entrepreneur
is a firefighter.
- Or a fixer.
I think I'm a fixer.
- You talking like gangster
shit like the fixer,
you call and he kills
someone, that kind of shit?
- No but someone's got a problem,
I don't care how big or small it is,
I will find the answer.
- Yeah, I think that's right.
You're the last line of defense.
- So what did you eat today?
- Nothing.
- I'm gonna fast today actually.
- The whole day?
- The whole day.
- So you do intermittent fasting
or you do more than that?
- No, I like doing,
actually I haven't done it
in about six or seven months
and I think I blame it for being up
about seven pounds more than I want to be.
It's real good for me.
I love it
and literally I just restarted,
yesterday was very light.
I had like four tiny crab legs.
I woke up this morning,
I'm like, yes, I need it,
I love it.
- That's so anorexic.
- No, isn't anorexia when
you throw up or is that--
- No, no, that's bulimia.
- Bulimia, got it.
Anorexia is just not eating?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I eat,
I just don't eat one day a week.
- So one full day, you drink water?
- That's a problem.
That is probably,
like I'm gonna drink some right now.
I'm a camel.
Actually, it's probably why I'm gonna die.
- Bite your tongue, first of all.
- Biting it.
- I didn't see it, okay good.
- Water and I have a
terrible relationship.
This is a very Eastern, I drink tea.
- Herbal, herbal.
- I love it, I drink--
- Well that's water.
- I know but even that I'm
not drinking enough of.
And honestly it's comfort food.
I grew up in a Russian household
where tea was around all the time.
I'm looking at Tyler 'cause it's funny.
I always have tea and coffee around
but I max out at like two
cups or a cup and a half.
I just need to have it there.
They probably have inside jokes of like
there's the tea and then
he's not gonna drink it.
It's literally a comfort food for me.
- But it's a lifestyle.
So if you wake up in the morning
and drink two glasses of water,
force it down 'cause Gary Vee can do
anything he puts his mind to,
- I believe that.
- It'll change everything about the way,
it'll change your metabolism, your brain,
not that you need
to be changed.
- You'll never believe
where my brain goes.
I like you so much--
- Oh Gar.
- That I'm gonna really try to do this now
only so I can reference your
podcast in public speeches
for the next four years.
- Aw, I know.
Why do we like each other so much?
I just thought it was me.
- I think we're very similar.
- Guess what?
I think my family's from Belarus.
- See?
- Like I'm not kidding.
- We're probably related.
- Yeah.
But I don't know my last name.
- Yeah, it's Brownshevik
or something.
- No, it's not.
No, we don't know.
- Oh right, that's not
your maiden name.
What's your maiden name?
- No, my maiden name Brown
but my grandfather changed his name
when he came to this country.
- Of course
'cause he was like Dimitry Buchabof
and he's like Brown.
By the way, really funny thing
about having VaynerMedia,
this whole Vayner thing that I'm building
every company with it,
my dad when he came to America,
immigration tried to get
him to drop the Chuk.
They're like, "You
should be Sasha Vayner."
And he was like, "No, I'm Vaynerchuk."
- Oh, you should name your next kid Chuck.
- I wish I could have another kid.
My wife is so against it.
- Oh, get me to your wife one more time.
- We will.
- I was 41 when I had
the baby who's now 20.
- That's fucking ama--
- It was amazing, it was.
- That's exactly right.
- And I wish I would've done a fourth.
No one ever says,
"Oh, I wish I didn't have that kid."
- My dad is the most
interesting guy on this issue.
He's really kind of like,
I call him a cactus
'cause he's tough on the outside
but he's a real kind of mush
if you really get to know him.
His great regret in life
is he promised my mom
we would have five kids,
that was the only thing my mom said,
they were like 19 in Russia.
She's like, "I want five kids."
He's like, "Cool."
We had three.
My mom was 31 when she had AJ.
She was a kid still.
And my dad was so scared
about paying for college
that he didn't want to have more kids
and he sits and talks
about it all the time,
the regret of like--
- But three is amazing.
I have three.
- Three's the best.
- And you have two
and your wife is so awesome, come on.
- You're preaching.
My parents are like, you
make such great kids,
you need to have more.
I'm like, I'm on board.
- Mostly I want to interview your wife
'cause what is it like
being married to Gary
that is always on, can't
go anywhere in public
without you being completely fanned over.
How does she deal with that?
- Easily, she's incredible.
She lives in her own cocoon.
I think one thing you may know
is we don't put out
content of her or our kids.
And so we play that pretty insular.
She doesn't give a shit
about any of this attention.
She's proud of me,
she knows me so well
and one of the people that knows
me the best if not the best
so she knows it's coming
from a good place,
so she likes that.
But she gets scared, she gets scared,
she definitely gets scared.
And so that's something
I think about as well.
- But when do you give her her time?
When is it just you and her?
- Weekends, seven weeks vacation
but the truth is we're
very much a 1957 couple.
It is absolutely a little
bit of a divide and conquer.
And we talk about that.
We know that that's something
that may have to evolve.
But it is definitely 1957.
- Meaning she's a stay-at-home mom,
you work and she makes sure
there's food on the table?
- Well no because I get home at 11:30 PM.
- You get home at 11:30 every night?
- I got home at 12:37 last night.
- When do you see your children?
I know you--
- Weekends, seven weeks vacation.
I'm absolutely not living
a politically correct
to everybody's work/life
balance standpoint
but I'm also unbelievably unphased by it
because I'm in a depth versus
width conversation in my life
and I'm also in, this
is this moment right now
and I'm always in a place of understanding
what will I regret,
how will I roll
and most importantly,
it's interesting, Lizzy
got me a plaque that said,
"My father taught me
how to live by living."
And I think a lot about that.
I think a lot about what
check boxes do I want to check
and for whom?
The most fascinating thing to go,
one of the reasons I love
when the four of us went out to dinner,
I remember when we left,
I was like, see, that's
the people we kind of need
to hang out with
because what's so
interesting to have dinner
with couples and things of--
- That was my husband and with Gary--
- Lizzy and all that.
- Yep.
- Everybody's just judging everybody.
The amount of six person dinners I go to
and people are like, "But
you're supposed to do this
"and you're supposed to do,"
I'm like, you don't know
anything about anything.
I don't want to judge,
I put out a lot of opinions
but they're macro.
They're not to DRock.
They're to the general public.
But I have nothing for
anybody on an individual basis
unless they ask.
I have no interest in judging
people's relationships
or how they raise their kids
or things of that nature
and I'm fascinated by how
many people like doing that.
- Then what are you curious about?
- Everything.
I'm unbelievably curious
about how people make decisions.
No question
which makes me then curious
about almost everything.
Communication, hence Vayner.
I'm very fascinated by what
gets people to do things,
inspires them to do things,
makes them not do things, comms.
I'm a boy that was born
in the Soviet Union
that came to America in the '80s.
I'm unbelievably, I think affected by that
when it comes to communication.
The fact that my mom wrote a book report
that she thought Fidel Castro
was the bravest man in
the world, blows my mind.
I'm like, wow.
And then so much of what's happening
in the political climate now
and with the internet and
things of that nature,
my life has always circled
around communication.
- Do you ever think of yourself at 70?
- A lot.
- And what do you think
you'll be doing at 70?
- Working a lot,
enjoying,
very similar version of what I am now,
enjoying whatever that may be.
My intuition is that I will evolve
into other things that
excite me and interest me
around communication.
I'm very quiet about my non-profit work
or some of the other stuff I do.
- Oh, could you tell me about it then?
What's your non-profit work?
- So I'm on the board
of Pencils of Promise.
I'm a well member at Charity Water
and I'm, laughing 'cause
I see Tyler over me,
I'm unbelievably fascinated by this,
people that donate to
causes or sit on boards
but then don't help acquaintances
or slight family members
or friends in times of need.
So my buckets break
into I'm very passionate
about Charity Water and Pencils of Promise
because they were founded and run
and not run anymore on Pencils of Promise
but at the time when I joined them,
they were founded and
run by young individuals
that were treating them more
like start-ups than NGOs
and I love the whole 80% of the money
wasn't going to the executives of it
and people weren't on the board
'cause they just wanted to rub
elbows with other important,
all the things I became like oh my God,
this is what NGOs are about.
So that was exciting.
But the third bucket for me
is I'm unbelievably
passionate about helping
people that I even
slightly've met three times
when they have cancer or their house,
again, I'm looking at
Tyler 'cause he knows,
this is something I've
never said publicly,
the most interesting thing
about how I think about
it is I feel guilty
to only do macro things like
cure the water issue in Africa
when somebody I've had dinner with
three times around business has a GoFundMe
'cause she has breast cancer.
I'm like, fuck, I have to give to that.
I don't want to be ideolog,
people love to do things
for their public pers,
the reason I don't talk about non-profit
is 'cause I watch all
my other friends use it
to tell the world that
they're a good person.
- Well, I don't mind talking about it
if it's gonna do some good.
- I agree.
- So we started a thing
called Reaching Out Montclair
which just helps the
underserved in Montclair.
It will never go outside
of Montclair, New Jersey.
And we see it first on.
We got kids costumes this weekend,
we had authors come and read books.
We get people mattresses.
- It's real.
And Montclair's an interesting comp.
Montclair and Summit has
this and other places,
I'm very fascinated by towns
that really have the
"other side of the tracks."
It's a very micro dynamic that
what I loved about when I saw that,
I looked at it for a few minutes,
I look at nothing,
I'm like oh, I like that
because I was always weirded out
by the extreme,
I did so much direct mail for Wine Library
when I was building that
store in New Jersey,
I know everything about
every zip code in New Jersey.
And so it's so funny when I meet people,
they're like, oh, I'm from Bergan,
I'm like, which town?
And I'm like, I know that.
113, median income.
I know stuff about Jersey
and Summit, Montclair,
couple other places,
they're fascinating to me, Westfield,
where you have these big micro climates,
I'm using wine terminology
where this side is like
homes that are a million
and that side is really not.
- And our kids all go to
school in the same place.
My kids went to the public school--
- Which oh by the way is amazing.
- Yeah.
- Which is the greatest thing for the kids
on the good side of the track.
- Yeah, Montclair High to
Stanford, the first kid.
- Love it.
School's broken in America, quick take.
It's so fucking broken
that I can't breath.
It's so broken.
Does anybody understand
the world we actually live in?
- Yes.
Well I think college is the
worst thing in the world,
that kids can't afford to go to college.
You need to start a college.
You need to start a free college.
I think that would
probably be your legacy.
- It's funny, when you said 70,
I'm like, I'm gonna fuck up college,
it ran through my mind.
- You didn't graduate or you did?
- Yes I did
but I went to Mount Ida College.
I majored in--
- So what's wrong with that?
- What's wrong with it?
Literally the mic that we're talking into
could get admitted.
Literally if you're,
dead people can get
into Mount Ida College.
Actually, Mount Ida College
went out of business recently.
This is a fun fact,
literally went out of business
after 100 plus, 200 years.
I think UMass Amherst like absorbed it.
What's wrong with it?
I played Madden for 98%
of my college experience.
- And you got an A in
Madden so that's good.
I went to Emerson College.
I showed up the day before
with my transcripts,
they let me in.
They said, "What do you want to major in?"
I said, "Makeup."
They said, "Okay."
I said, "Do you have a makeup program?"
They said, "No."
I said, "Alright, I'll make it up."
And I went to Emerson.
Now you can't get into Emerson.
Now it's a tough school.
- Yeah, honestly--
- So don't be embarrassed by--
- Embarrassed?
Nobody propoganda's it more than me.
I post my report card
with a 247 out of 251.
The only thing I'm proud of in my life
is that I'm a shit student,
that I fucking spit in
the face of the system
when nobody else was doing it back then.
- But it is not gonna work
for all the other kids that
are listening out there.
It's your journey,
it's not gonna be someone else's journey.
- That's right.
And the clarity that I always
want to say about college
is like, look, if you want
to work at Goldman Sachs,
you better get good ass grades
and you better go to Wharton,
you better go to Harvard.
You have to know yourself
and know what you want.
If you're an entrepreneur,
if you truly are,
here's the scariest scenario
with education in America today.
You're an entrepreneur and
you're passionate about it
and you can't breath if you don't do it
and you're okay if you make
80,000 a year selling pillows
or you go and build Uber
and your parents make you take on debt
to go to a shitty college
'cause they want to feel
good that you went to college
to their other friends,
that to me is scary as fuck.
- But everyone has different
stories and different journeys.
See this girl right here?
- Yes.
- She, when I left Bobbi Brown Cosmetics
I went to the Apple store,
I had three hours of work there,
she was such a rock star, I hired her.
She's gone to a two year college,
she, I don't know where you would've been
if I didn't pick you up that day.
- She would be at VaynerMedia
running the company.
- Well, she now is everything
and does all of our content.
- That's right.
Listen, Drock homeschooled,
I don't know where the,
it's all the same shit.
Tyler's a dope.
He got into Penn State 'cause--
- Tyler graduated from Montclair High.
- Yeah, but he's a dope.
Come on.
Listen, every winner that I like, dope.
I'm the biggest dope of them all.
My definition,
the reality is the world changed.
College was built to create workers
for an environment that was
much more mapped to 1959
and that's wonderful
and it was a great era
and Mazel Tov and all good but guess what?
If you're taking on debt
to go to college today,
unless you're going to a
top three percent school,
you're in deep fucking shit.
- So why can't we have a college
that the kids are actually entrepreneurs
the whole time?
- They're going to.
All of this is gonna happen.
- I think you and Richard
Baker have to do that together.
- I think people should stop
telling people what to do.
You should do it.
- No, no, this is more of
a Gary thing, I'm sorry.
- Look, I think what's actually happening
is it's already happening
without people realizing it,
meaning, one of the things
that I'm most excited
about the content that I put out,
especially on Instagram
'cause it skews young
at least for now,
it's obviously aging up
quickly which is amazing.
You're changing people's thought,
I was on a FaceTime with
a woman in India yesterday
on Snapchat 'cause Tyler
she won it, what happened?
Or did I see her on
Twitter, what happened?
- [Tyler] Instagram, she
put up the best caption.
- She won.
I was on a seven minute FaceTime yesterday
with a woman who was sitting in India
telling me that she has to decide
between going to Australia for school
or staying in India for two more years
because she wants to get
an Indian citizenship
'cause she's got a Pakistani citizenship
and she wants to be discriminated
against a little less.
It was really powerful,
as you can imagine.
And I'm sitting there
and I'm just thinking
about all these things.
I'm like, we live in a world
where I'm in a car right now
talking on FaceTime through Snapchat
with a young woman in India
where my words are about to impact
her making a life decision.
You want to talk about--
- It's pretty crazy.
- It's super crazy.
- It's insane.
- Nobody's making that,
that's not something Star Trek
or Star Wars thought about
when they were making up
what the world would look like in 2018.
They thought about flying cars,
they fucked up.
But all this other internet stuff,
we didn't know.
And so the ground rules of our society
are changing remarkably--
- Which is your favorite platform?
Mine is Instagram 'cause
I'm a visual person.
- You know what's funny,
I'm unbelievably native to Twitter
because I love community management.
I love engaging with people
and Twitter's so easy to do that.
I can just see them all in that format.
Instagram's been remarkable,
to the very nice comment that you made
of like people now knowing who I am,
no question Instagram,
podcast and YouTube's
from three years ago when I
really made a commitment there,
if I had to pick a favorite,
if you said to me, you've got to keep one,
I would keep Instagram right now
because the number one asset that I chase
is people's attention
and that is where it is.
And so that's why I
would have to pick that.
- And I heard yesterday that John Mayer
has a new talk show on Instagram.
- That's awesome.
I didn't see that.
- I thought that
was pretty cool, never thought of that.
- John Mayer, my favorite guy, awesome.
I love that dude.
He's super smart
like super creatively interesting.
One of the more interesting people
I've sat down with in the last 10 years,
just an interesting dude.
- How come he's not married with kids?
- I don't know him well
enough to even take a guess
but I know that how he
thinks about creativity
and attention and communication
which is the foundation of
the long conversation we had,
I think he really understands.
- And who have you not met
that you're dying to get
on your show or talk to?
- You know, it's funny,
I don't know why that doesn't,
that's hard for me to answer,
the only person I ever
wish I'd met that I didn't
that I never will be able to
is Randy the Macho Man Savage.
That's devastating to me.
I would've liked to get that at-bat.
- Okay, I'm so sorry, I
don't know who that is.
- Alright, let's cancel this.
Thanks for having me on, Bobbi.
- Who's that?
- He's the greatest fucking
wrestler of all time.
- Okay.
I had a wrestler at my sweet 16.
- Who?
- I don't know, two women wrestlers.
My Papa Sam got him for me.
- Wendy Richter?
- I don't know, I'm from Chicago.
Papa Sam got 'em as entertainment.
- They wrestled?
- They wrestled, two women wrestlers.
I don't know, Papa knew
someone that knew someone
and they came.
- That's some good shit.
- Yeah, so no, sorry I didn't
know your wrestler friend.
- I love how everybody now gets Drake
but you had two women wrestlers.
- I actually went to a bar
mitzvah where Drake performed
before he was Drake.
- I got it, he referenced it.
I know what you're talking about.
- Nobody.
- Nobody?
That's the actual truth meaning--
- How 'bout your dad?
Have you ever gotten
your dad on your show?
- I have and it's really good.
When me and my dad jam,
it's really good.
I really like it.
And I'll be honest with you,
I like it for one reason only,
that my great great
grandkids are gonna watch it.
I'm obsessed with people not understanding
what's actually happening
which is that everybody
that's living right now
is gonna actually be the
patriarch and matriarch
of their family's in perpetuity
'cause the most content is
gonna be created about us.
So that in 400 years,
we're gonna be the starting
point of our families
'cause our great grandparents
and our parents and our
great great grandparents,
there's some random pictures
but with us,
there's gonna be like unlimited content.
- Yeah, that's pretty cool.
- I think it's very cool.
- So you give advice all the time.
If there's one thing you
could tell people right now
to do right now that would
change the course of their life,
one thing.
- Communicate the poison
that's in their head
to the person that needs to hear it.
- Tell me more.
- Every single person listening
has something to say to
somebody they love very much
that is bothering the fuck out of them.
- Do you do that?
- Yeah.
- You let it go, you tell people?
- I only give advice I take.
The reason I'm in such a happy place
is I overcommunicate even
when it's uncomfortable
and that has taken me a long,
I run in pockets.
I do a very bad job of it
with people that I'm still
trying to get to a place.
Employees.
I'm really bad with radical candor,
I've gotten dramatically better
but I'm not as good as I can be
'cause I'm still optimistic
that I can get them into a place
of self awareness or output
that will make them successful.
You know who I would have been?
- Hm?
- I would've absolutely
been the young teenage girl
that always chased the bad boy
thinking that I could
get him to a good place.
That is absolutely my DNA.
- And then you picked
the most perfect, normal
woman you could find.
- Yes.
- Yes, that's very telling.
- Unbelievably.
- I like that.
So you've got a normal side
under your Gary Veeness.
- I'm unbelievably normal.
- Which people don't believe.
But I saw that in you the first time.
- I am a tortoise in a hare's costume.
- Okay, that's taking me a second
to work its way through my head.
- My energy and personality
confuse the fuck out of people
because they shouldn't spend
the time figuring me out.
But the people that are closest to me
are completely the other, no,
are completely the other way
'cause they know who I am.
They're always around me.
You can't hide.
So yeah, I would say,
I think I'm the most normal.
And this is a funny statement
but let me say where I'm
actually going with it.
I'm dramatically practical.
I'm most comfortable when I'm in business,
I don't go to things.
It's so funny when I go to a public thing,
especially over the last year or two
where I think more people know who I am--
- Since you've blown up.
He won't say but yes.
- People freak out,
not because I'm cool,
it's 'cause I'm never out.
It's just supply and demand.
When I go to a public thing,
it's like I'm just never out.
I'm literally, like last night,
I got home at 12:37
because I was in seven different meetings
between seven PM and,
that's the only place--
- And when you got home,
did you get in bed and go to sleep
or do you need to wind down at night?
- Luckily, Lizzy and I hung
and chatted for 15 minutes,
I went to sleep.
- She waited up for you?
- Yeah, she waits up for me a lot.
- Oh my God, that woman.
- She's all time.
- That woman, that's pretty awesome.
Do you think you'll be the dad
that shows up at all the games?
- No.
- You don't think so?
- But I show up at a ton of stuff.
Again, I'm just looking at
these over your shoulder,
the Montclair Mafia
and he knows all the truth,
we fight like hell to be at everything.
But if I'm--
- No, but your kid's things?
Do you think you'll be
the teacher's conferences?
- We fight like hell to
be at everything but if I,
I've booked a speech
for April 14th already.
- That's my birthday, you cannot do that.
- Well, that's amazing, by the way,
that's the best moment,
by the way, that was
the moment of this show.
I love that shit.
By the way, I'm not even
sure if I've actually
booked a meeting
for April 14th--
- But that is actually
my birthday.
- I know which is what makes
the whole thing very chiasmic,
but I definitely have a
keynote somewhere in that range
and like I don't know, I'm
getting heavily compensated,
it's locked in,
I can't bail if tomorrow,
if on February 19th, Lizzy emails me
and Tyler and Alex and says to us,
"Hey, Gary needs to be at
this recital on April 14th,"
and then Tyler has to write
this scary email of like,
oh fuck, he's in San Francisco and then--
- Well then, I'll tell
you what you have to do.
You have to go into the
principal the first day and say,
"Dude, give me all the dates."
I put them in my calendar
And I don't book a speech on the dates.
- We do lock in, we do lock that in
but obviously, as you know, things pop up
and things could change
and snow days and all that horse shit
and plus, these private school kids
don't even go to fucking school.
By the way, that's the racket.
These fuckers don't go to,
first of all, they should
start private school
on October 1st
because literally between
fucking Jewish holidays
and all this other shit,
they're literally in school
three days in September.
- So send your kids to
public school in Montclair.
- I'm thrilled.
I'm not moving to Montclair.
- Why not?
- Oh my God,
this is actually a, I
think I told you this
the first time we hung out.
You know this, Tyler.
I always thought I was
gonna live in Montclair,
upper Montclair.
- Upper Montclair and
Montclair's kind of the same.
There's no difference,
there's no difference.
- I just know it based
on the zip code thing.
I, 'cause I had the store
in Springfield and Milbourne
and I was like, I don't
want to live in Short Hills,
too close to the store.
I wanted to have a little commute.
I wanted to have a little 15 minutes
to listen to some sports
radio in the morning.
And so I randomly just picked,
and Mendham used to be on my mind too.
But that seemed boring.
- If I didn't have the commute,
that hour or two hours a day,
I've written nine books and
I don't know how to type.
I do it in the back seat of a car.
I could do everything in
the back seat of a car.
I can't do it at a desk.
- I totally understand.
I've done the same,
I can't put a sentence together
and I've written six books.
- So when do you do it?
I do it when I'm--
- I do verbal.
So me and Stephanie,
I have a ghost writer, Stephanie Land,
whose incredible,
and we literally go into a cocoon,
like a room like this for a day or two,
and I just talk until the end.
- Okay, first of all,
I just heard about your new show
and it sounds unbelievable.
- Trash Talk?
It is.
- Unbelievable.
So tell us how Trash Talk came
and you don't really need
the cash, I don't think--
- No, I am not spending my
entire Saturday to make $613.
What's driving me is two things,
happiness is the ROI.
- No, but on this Trash Talk?
- I'm gonna explain.
- Okay fine.
- I'm not sure if there's any
place I'm happier in the world
then when I am actively
garage saleing in New Jersey
at 8:13 in the morning on a Saturday.
I am really, the Jets,
it's scary how close garage
saleing is to the Jets
and I would actually,
like I'm gonna have, I
want to be authentic,
I'm starting to even ask
myself questions of like, no,
no, the Jets are number one
because I was just thinking,
what if the best garage
sales were only on Sunday,
I would go to the Jets.
So Jets are number one,
and this is like selfish stuff,
like putting family on
a complete pedestal,
those seven weeks are the
engine that drive my life
but on a selfish kick,
garage saleing is just,
going to Verona the other day
which is I know close by to you guys,
going to Verona and going
into people's garages
and driveways and then,
once in awhile, you can go in the house,
that's when shit gets crazy
'cause I'm just trying to buy everything.
I love garage saleing.
Here's what's really driving me.
In this explosion,
an enormous amount of people follow me
who disproportionately are affected
by making 100 to 500 dollars more a month.
That means something for real.
All of my homies and contemporaries
are telling these people
to build the next Facebook.
I'm practical.
I know that anybody
who's listening right now
who genuinely needs an
extra hundred bucks a week,
the easiest,
and I don't use,
by the way, I hate the word easy,
the easiest way to make
100 bucks extra a week
is to go to thrift stores,
Goodwill, garage sales,
buy things and sell them on Ebay, OfferUp,
Facebook Marketplace.
- The Real Real, there's so many places.
- It's so scary.
I actually believe most people
could make between 50 to $100,000
if they're average at it.
When I think about all the
people making 37K a year,
when I think about all the
people grinding two jobs
working at Best Buy overnight
and something else during the day
and they're collectively
making 13 bucks an hour,
that's just real,
who could instead garage
sale and go to Goodwill,
buy and flip shit on Ebay--
- Or in addition.
- Or in addition
but when you're working two jobs,
but honestly, Bobbi,
you'll appreciate this,
this is back to practicality, or,
here's my big thing,
just try it for a little while,
see if you can do it.
I do think that the average skilled person
after a couple months gets
to 20 or 30 bucks an hour.
- Did you ever read the
book Nickel and Dimed?
- No but it sounds exciting.
- Well, it's about people
that actually live their life
as waitresses and working at Walmart,
no, it's unbelievable how hard it is.
No, it's just it's
unbelievable how hard it is
and God forbid, someone
gets sick and God forbid--
- Oh, it's devastating
or the tire blows.
Listen, the great thing of
going to Mount Ida College
is 97% of my friends and
contemporaries and classmates
were in awfully bad situations
like welfare, like bad, bad.
Two great things happened.
One, I disproportionately
collected a lot of swag
and two, it gave me perspective
that is unbelievably uncomfortable.
And what I know is I'm
passionate about this
because I'm showing people how to fish.
And it's working.
- Are you still friends
with anyone you went to college with?
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Tokyo Joe, Moose.
- Okay, hey guys.
- I'm on this incredible thread
where like every time,
we literally talk, ironically,
we literally talk football,
it's unbelievable how much
smack talk goes on in there.
- That's so cool.
You can tell a lot by someone
by being friends with their friends.
- I couldn't agree more.
- Well talk to me about the shoes
'cause I'm very excited to wear mine
once I get the right size.
I think they're so cool.
By the way, this is my color, the blue.
It's the Caribbean,
I'm still waiting for
you to come to my house.
- I know, you're amazing, you're so sweet.
- My number one thesis in business
is that nostalgia is underpriced.
I'm obsessed with it.
I believe,
and I think Marvel proved it
by taking IP and reforming it.
And so I'm very excited about
doing those kind of things
in the future in my career
and no question, the most
significant test case of my thesis
has been this collaboration
I did with K-Swiss
where literally there's a Gary Vee shoe.
I'm taking my shoe off
'cause I get so excited when I see this.
My signature's on a shoe.
That is ludicrous.
- And the bottom of the shoe.
- Yes, we talk about
like the definition.
- Damn, I should have
brought my shoes.
I want you to actually really sign them.
- And so Bobbi, it's really cool
because for you and I,
unlike these kids that
are in the room here,
we may remember a time
where K-Swiss had a whole,
pre-Nike, if you Google K-Swiss culture
or if you type K-Swiss 1980s,
you'll see pictures of Ice
T, Mike Tyson, Dr. Dre,
they were really,
so for me,
when I was young and affected
by MTV Raps and the culture
and Edison had great diversity
and so I was very into early hip hop.
Man, K-Swiss was cool.
I wore my K-Swiss on the
first day to fifth grade,
like I made it
and then they weren't
cool for a very long time.
And so to reboot it as an
entrepreneurial sneaker
for me to have the kind of strategy
in what I've done with
influencer marketing
and marketing with it,
to watch it now be a thing
that is popping a little bit,
not only my sneakers
but the whole brand
has been really a great
business case study
where it's been great to reward Barney
and the people at K-Swiss
who took a chance on me,
who signed me to the deal,
maybe before this pop moment.
So they obviously, that worked out.
The whole thing's great.
Watching Barney run around and do keynotes
and things of that nature, has been fun
and Patrick and the whole team.
The whole situation has been fun.
Tyler, we keep referencing him,
as a nice Montclair boy,
has been deeply involved in it
and it's been fun for him,
who loves sneakers and that culture,
to have say in design or distribution.
So it's been a great thing for my team,
it's been a great thing,
I mean I always say things like
would nine year old me,
I love that game, right,
nine year old me,
if you told nine year old me
that I had a sneaker
with my signature on it,
I would've laughed you out of the room.
I'm working on a deal right now,
do I have that call this week?
I'm not telling you,
but I'm working on a deal right now
that really the nine
year old me would be like
get the fuck out of here.
- You're buying the Jets.
- Nope.
But, by the way, you know
what's funny about that,
that's the only thing that feels normal.
- Is buying the Jets?
- I once told, when AJ and I got,
so we got courtside seats to
the Knicks couple years ago
and we sat there and
we looked at each other
and I looked at him like, man,
I saw nothing in between
scrappy immigrant boy
and buying the Jets.
All the shit in the middle,
like fancy people inviting
me to Baker's Bay,
I'm being serious,
Knicks, sneakers, all of it, nice office,
saw none of it.
Even make fun of myself of like
how did you think it was gonna go down?
Like literally make fun of
myself when I talk to myself,
I'm like, that's how it actually,
you don't just go from,
what are we gonna win the lottery?
I didn't see my life.
I didn't see all the neat things.
I'm also not into,
Drock said something to me the other day
about the process versus things
or the things that the things get you,
he was telling me basically like man,
it was just a very honest moment,
he obviously follows
me around all the time,
it was a unique moment,
we were in Australia and he was like,
"Man, people just don't understand
how you live your life."
I don't like stuff.
I like experiences
and that's why the Baker's
thing or the Knicks thing,
I get pumped about
but stuff I don't like.
And even experiences,
I'm not even sure how
much I really like them.
- Well you don't have time.
- I like the process, I like the game,
I like competing.
I like inspiring.
I live for the DMs of like,
look, I got a crazy DM,
just back to Trash Talk like fuck it,
I want everybody to hear this.
I got a DM from a woman
that the DM starts with,
I have been a prostitute for
the last 12 years of my life
and in the last week
is the first time I've ever felt
that I don't have to do
this profession anymore
because I've made a
couple thousand dollars
buying tee shirts,
I've always had a knack for fashion
and I've been going to thrift stores
after your Trash Talk stuff
and buying clothes and selling it
and I've made so much money,
fuck everything I ever do--
- Did you answer her?
- I didn't.
- 'Cause I get some of
those weird things too.
- And it was super,
I felt super comfortable answering it,
I wasn't worried like, do I
answer, 'cause a prostitute,
I wasn't worried about that.
I didn't 'cause I'm just
gonna tell you the truth,
probably because I said,
"Fuck everything I ever do in my life,"
it took me into such a place of happiness.
I'm like, do you know how many
people live their entire life
never inspiring anybody for good
including their children?
A lot.
- Do you know what
would make me happy?
- What?
- Drink this whole thing down
while we're sitting here.
- Okay, appreciate it, no problem.
- Okay, Gary is now drinking my water.
- I would literally rather right now
put a boulder on my back
and walk to Afghanistan
than drink this bottle of water.
- No 'cause I want you to go out
and while you're in the
car say to your guys,
"Huh, my headache just went away.
"Oh, I could do more
"than I do today."
- I never get headaches.
- You never get headaches?
- I wish Lizzy was here.
One time I got one,
I was like, "Hey, wife,
what's this feeling?"
She's like, "You have a fucking headache."
I was like, "Oh weird."
It was super weird.
I never get headaches.
- Okay, finish the water
and then I'm gonna ask you
your favorite cocktail.
- I literally think my
dehydration is my strength.
- That's impossible.
And your skin looks good.
- Is it?
- Yes, it's impossible,
yes, no, it's impossible.
- No, I know.
By the way, I genuinely
believe this is true.
I genuinely think the great
demise of my entire empire
is gonna be water.
- No, but I see a Gary
Vee water coming out,
I'm just saying, opportunity.
Alright, you did a
pretty good job.
- Oh my God, I feel terrible.
- Yay!
Well Gary, thanks so much
for being on my show,
but it's really your show.
- No, it's your show.
How much time do we have?
- [Tyler] Seven more minutes.
- Yeah Bob, let's do something.
- I always think I'm boring people.
- What about eighth place trophies?
- Eight place--
- Eighth place trophies.
- What'd you get?
- No, no, do you like,
in Montclair, are they giving trophies
to fourth place teams?
- [Female] First, second and third winner.
- What are you like
completely confused by this?
- No, I'm looking at,
you know Gretchen's grandfather
was a guy named Yogi Berra?
- That's fucking amazing.
- Yeah.
Montclair guy, Montclair guy,
she was my assistant when
she was a young girl,
she was the first girl I ever brought
to Take Your Daughter to
Work Day, Gretchen Berra,
and now she is I don't even,
she doesn't have a title.
She does so much with me.
- Omnipresent.
- Yeah, she does.
- No but this,
it's super cool that you transitioned
to one of the great athletes of all time.
I'm fascinated by,
I'm so positive that
America's in deep shit.
Nothing is more obvious to me
than when you create
entitlement, it's all over.
As a matter of fact,
let's talk about transparency.
The great vulnerability of
VaynerMedia in its nine years
was two, three years ago,
when I had to wake up and say, fuck,
I care about feelings and
culture and empathy so much,
I've quietly created entitlement here
where merit isn't put on a pedestal,
where being kind is,
but you kinda suck at your job.
And I have a lot of work to
do over the next three years
to fix this.
- But when it comes to sports,
and especially when you're a kid,
I mean being a mom that watched my kids
in all the different sports,
and yes, if you get fourth
place and whatever place,
it's a little bit of a confidence builder.
It's like, okay--
- I'm out of here.
- Okay.
- Bobbi--
- You have to.
- Bobbi!
- There's some chubby fat kid
whose like barely making--
- Who needs to understand,
yo chubby fat kid,
you're not gonna be a
professional fucking athlete.
Go be a great
fucking architect.
- You're in third grade.
- I don't give a fuck.
- Hey Arty, the fat ass,
you're gonna be a great chef
but get the fuck off the
football field, you suck.
- But I just think
everyone's good at something.
- That's right.
So get off the fucking football field.
But guess what?
Mommy Bobbi over here's tricking you
and making you think you might be okay.
- No, no, no, no.
- Yes, yes.
- Is his microphone louder than mine
or does he just talk louder?
I'm trying to figure it out.
- I'm fucking pissed out here.
You're a fucking gangster winner
and this is what I'm worried about.
- But I'm compassionate.
- You got me into water,
I'm getting you into true,
fifth place trophies,
Bobbi, there's a reason that
people are struggling mentally
and I'm telling you everybody
wants to blame social media.
It's bullshit.
It's parents creating fake
environments for children.
We're building zoo animals.
These fucking kids are zoo animals.
- Explain that, zoo animals.
That we're watching them.
What does that mean?
- It means when you take
a tiger from the Bronx Zoo
and you put it in the actual jungle,
he fucking or she dies in one second
because they've not grown up
in the actual environment.
You take kids who fucking
think they're good at baseball
because at Montclair up
until fucking 12th grade,
everybody's fucking good
and then you actually go and play baseball
and you get fucking struck
out 900 times in a row,
you go back to your dorm room
and start doing fucking cocaine.
- Oh come on, Gary, it
doesn't work like that.
- That's exactly actually--
- It does not.
- Whoa, listen,
look at the kid's faces.
- Did you play baseball?
- [Male] No, I played football.
- Football, okay.
- He did fucking cocaine.
- But you knew at one point,
you're like, okay, this
was really cool and fun.
Alright, this isn't gonna work.
- No because mommy tricked me
because we had fucking sundaes
after losing 31 to nothing
but we made pretend we didn't keep score.
- Guess what?
- What?
- No.
If you're not good at football
and you love the sport,
so go work for the team.
There's ways to take your passion--
- There you go, keep
building, keep building.
- No, but it's true.
I watched my kids,
I had a pro golfer,
I had kids that were
good at different things
and then they weren't anymore.
They entered high school,
they were on traveling soccer and baseball
their entire careers
until they went to high school,
they realized they're not gonna make it
and they didn't so they moved on.
- That's fine.
Listen, a lot of people don't move on
and creating fake environments
is an issue that needs to
be talked about much more
and I think you should create
a fake environment school.
- The fourth place and
the eighth place kid,
you don't know what you're
gonna encourage him,
so maybe the next season
he'll be in the third place.
There's ways to get--
- No, no, fake environments
doesn't mean mean,
it means just don't create delusion.
- I mean look, I teach and I
empower young entrepreneurs,
girls, makeup artists that come to me
and everyone and their uncle now
besides having a media
platform and a podcast
has a makeup line.
- That's right, everybody.
- I give everyone advice
and the advice is, be different,
have a point of difference
and every day of your fucking life,
you have to work really, really hard.
- On a very serious note,
like straight no bullshit,
this is gonna be the
best part of the podcast,
what percentage of the
people that you meet
that tell you they're gonna
start a makeup line, do you,
this is one woman's point of view,
you may be wrong, you may
be right, I'm just curious,
what percentage do you think will actually
have a successful business that
whether it has an exit
or it pays for their livelihood,
a true successful business?
- Well, I think it's very
low, for sure, it's very low
but what is success?
When I left, it was a billion dollars.
That is not normal.
That's not normal.
- No, no, no.
Success to me is they get to do it
and they can live their life.
As a matter of fact,
the number one thing I'm trying to,
and I know my team is seeing me
start to go in this direction,
I'm starting to get
interested about expenses,
not how much you make.
My big thing is that successes,
if you wanted to be the
eye shadow king or queen,
that's a great life.
You love eye shadow,
you want to live forever
doing this eye shadow thing,
by the way, I think you could
make $109,000 a year in profit
and actually be a success because--
- Well, I believe in profit, number one.
I don't believe in investments.
- You heard what I said.
If you make $109,000 in profit
by creating an eyeshadow
and selling it on Shopify and Ebay
and you live in a household
and your expenses equal
88,000 for the year,
you're gonna win.
The problem is everybody
wants a fucking BMW
and everybody fucking wants
to buy $800,000 handbags
and everybody fucking lives on credit
and overextends themselves
and overlever, you know
why you and I like profit?
Because we know that the
next economic downturn
all these businesses that
everybody thinks are doing well
are gonna go out of business.
- Well I have so many of my friends
that are like wanting to
hand me millions of dollars,
they're venture guys,
to start new businesses
and I'm like, no.
First of all, besides
I think it's ridiculous
to spend more money than you have.
- Bobbi, of course they
want to give you money,
their lives are about raising capital,
taking a percentage of it
and then giving it to people
that actually do shit.
- And one of them told me
I never have to worry
about making a profit.
And I'm like, that's all I
know how to do is make profits.
- I want to kill everybody.
- No you don't, you're positive.
- I'm like a business athlete.
When I say I want to kill everybody,
I'm like the athlete
that plays on the field
and I want to do everything dirty
and get away with it to win the game.
As soon as the game's over,
I want to shake your hand and
ask you how your wife's doing
and donate to your charity.
But on the field, I
want to kill everybody.
And so I think that is something
I need to create more clarity of.
A lot of the alpha competitive,
I want to destroy every body's face,
that's kind of business.
That's like when I'm in the game.
You're like that.
- Oh 100%.
- Back in the day, when a
buyer didn't buy something,
you walked out of there and you're like,
I'm gonna fucking kill her.
- No, I would just say,
"Why, tell me why,"
and I'd say, "Let me tell you
why I think it's so good,"
and they'd say okay.
- But when she was still a
schpameal and made a big mistake,
you'd walk out and be like,
I'm gonna destroy carrot.
- Right but you know
I'm still in the game.
- I know you're still in the game.
- I still have a couple businesses
that are about to blow up
which I can't wait to tell you.
- I feel like you're
rising like a phoenix.
- A phoenix.
- That's what I think is going on here.
- First of all, I think being
on your show that one time
was like, oh my God,
all these random people
that I haven't talked to
or seen in years are like,
oh my God, you know Gary Vee?
I want...
Young people want an introduction
which I have never once said,
well only once, just an intern I know,
but that was about it.
- I'm so flattered when I hear this shit.
I really wish people could
feel flattered more often.
Do you know, I'm very good
at giving compliments.
I like razzing my team, it's out of love
but I love giving compliments
'cause it's so nice.
Why can't we make that more cool?
That's a cool new agenda.
That might be the best part of this.
We need to get, I love it.
I'm so funny at it.
Right now, I love telling
people, I love your yellow coat
like in the airport
and people like freak out.
It's like the nicest thing
or just looking at people and smiling,
we need to make positivity louder.
What?
- I always stop women and I say,
"Oh my God, you're so pretty."
And they look at me.
I'm like, well, I'm Bobbi Brown,
I'm not trying to pick you up.
- Yeah, if I,
I do it to dudes.
Obviously, you need to be careful
even not in this political climate,
you always want to be respectful.
It's not even careful,
that's the wrong word.
But I love doing it to dudes.
I love telling Tyler when
he has a good haircut
which by the way, I've never done
which means he's never had a good haircut.
But we're still hoping.
- Aw, I just think it's so crazy, Tyler.
I knew him when he was a little kid.
It's just crazy.
- I know, we're so proud
of him, right?
- It's crazy, yeah,
he's gonna be something.
- He really is.
You know what's funny?
Tyler is very motivating for me
because when he came to me,
AJ and him, you know,
but watching, and by the
way, this is a joke on Tyler
but this is every admin
assistant, every team member,
watching people realize
they can do so much more
is one of the most
intoxicating things for me
of being a manager.
I don't think people realize
how much shit they can fit in a day.
- But you didn't just hire him
to be your second in command?
- Tyler was hired through an
introduction from a great guy,
Mickey Cloud, who runs
our Chattanooga office
and back then we were doing a
lot of community management.
You would reply on Twitter as a brand.
Then AJ needed an admin,
and Tyler's so charismatic,
you know Tyler, again, he's a dope
but he's so charismatic he wins.
So he's so charismatic.
So somehow it hits AJ's
radar so he's interested.
The best story of all time
and Tyler knows where I'm about to go,
day one, this is real,
day one, Tyler is my brother's admin
which means he's in his inbox.
We get an email from the New York Jets
which is a client
which you can imagine I'm so in love with
and literally the email says,
"Hey AJ, I'd like to schedule a call.
"I'd like to request Tyler Schmidt
"be removed from the Jets account."
- Why?
- 'Cause he stinks, guys, he's a dope.
I've been trying to tell you.
The same reason I got D's and F's,
players in positions to succeed.
If you are an entrepreneur
or you run a business
or you're a manager,
you work for everybody else
and your number one job in the world
is to put other people
in a place to succeed
predicated on their skills
and passion overlay.
- But I think the most important thing
for all of us dopes that didn't
get good grades in school
is to figure out what we're not good at
and try to work around it.
Either get someone else to do it.
I never learned how to type
and I've written nine books.
So there's so many of those things.
- I'm the greatest fucking
public speaker in the world
and if you asked me to read
this in front of this room
I would shiver, I can't read.
- You could, you just choose not to.
- Yes.
- Do you read books?
- No.
I've written more books than I've read.
- So are you ADD or OCD?
- Probably.
- I'm both.
I'm self diagnosed.
- I have no interest
in letting anybody
arbitrarily diagnose me.
They can keep that in their pocket.
I'm me, I'm intuitive
to what makes me happy
and I keep trying
to become a better
version of that every day
and then I try to overarticulate that
so that it might impact somebody else
because there is nothing that
feels better than admiration.
I live for admiration.
- And speaking of admiration,
the way I actually first heard about you,
I just remembered, in
the backyard of my house
when I was in the Jersey Shore,
there were these kids playing spike ball.
I went up to this one kid and I said,
"Let me talk to you about your eyebrows."
It was Nick.
- Dio.
His eyebrows are a disaster.
And he's such a good looking dude.
I want to hook up with him
but his eyebrows are like, nah, I'll pass.
His eyebrows need to be addressed.
- And he said, "You've got
to come in and meet my boss."
And I Googled you and I'm like, who?
I never heard of you, I'm like who?
And it took me a year
and when I came in we talked for an hour
and the next day I find out you filmed me.
And I remember I'm like,
filmed you and I called Nick.
He's like, "What did you expect?"
I'm like, I didn't know that.
- How were you confused
with all the huge cameras in the room?
- I was so focused on you,
I did not see a camera, a thing, I do not.
- Guys, everybody listen to this podcast,
bad always loses, promise.
We've been around a long fucking time.
It doesn't feel like that way, I promise--
- But sometimes we have
to wait a long time
like eight years, four years.
- Sure, six.
There's all sorts of numbers.
Alright, we're out of here, see you, bye.
- Okay bye.